you describe the goals of a blockchain
you have a nice presentation on this as
scalability security and
decentralization and you challenge the
blockchain trilemma that claims you can
only have two of the three
so let's talk about each what is
scalability in the context
of blockchain and cryptocurrency what
does scalability mean
so remember if we said that the
blockchain
is a ledger and each page receives a
get start transaction and everybody can
write in this
in these pages of a ledger nobody can be
stopped for writing and everybody can
read them
okay scalability means how fast can you
write
just imagine that you can write an entry
in this uh
spatial shared ledger once every hour
well you know what you're going to do if
you ever know one transaction per hour
the world that doesn't go around so you
need to have scalability means here that
you can somehow write a lot
of transaction and then you can read
them
and everybody can validate them and that
is the speed
and and this and and the number of
transactions on
per second and the fact that they are
shared so you want to have
this this uh the speed not only in
writing but in
in sharing and uh and uh inspection for
validity
this is scalability but the world is big
the world wants to interact with the
people want to interact with each other
and you better be prepared to have a
ledger in which you can write lots and
lots and lots of
transactions in this special way very
very very quickly
so maybe from a more mathematical
perspective or
can we say something about how much
scalability
is needed for a world that is big
well it really depends how many
transactions are you want but
remember veteran i i think you know
right now yet to go into at least
thousands of transactions or
um per second even if you look at the
norm um
credit cards right you know we are going
to go from
an average of 1600 to peaks over 20 000
or
40 000 something like this but
but remember it's not only a question of
the transaction per se but the value is
that
the transaction is actually being shared
and visible
to everybody and the certainty that that
is the case
i can print on my own printer
way more transactions but nobody has the
time to see or
to inspect that doesn't count right so
you want
scalability at this common knowledge
level and that is the challenge
i also meant from a perspective of like
uh like a complexity analysis
so does it you know when you get more
and more people involved
doesn't need to scale in some kind of
way that uh
like do you do you like to see certain
kind of properties in order to say
something is scalable
oh absolutely i took a little bit
implicitly that
the people transacting are actually very
different
so if there is a two people who can do a
fascination per second with each other
this is not so interesting
what we really need is to save billions
of people and at any point in time you
know thousands and thousands of them
want to transact with each other and you
want to support
that
you